if men want respect as it's to be left
alone how many women are always nagging
their husbands to do things they're not
respecting them we see respect as
allowing something to maintain its
original function if you respect the
building you don't put graffiti on it
you keep it clean if you respect a
person you allow them to maintain their
function that's been like a cool frame
for guys to be like does she respect me
it's like well does she allow you to
maintain your function whether it's I
want to stay to the gym if she says
don't do that or I would have worked on
this thing and she says no we need to go
out with these friends like she's not
respecting what you want to do